connaissez-vous leur point commun toutes
et tous ont été des politiques
évidemment mais dans leur jeunesse
toutes et tous ont été scouts
[Applaudissements]
avec ces camps en pleine nature sa
méthode éducative basée sur le jeu et
l'autonomie le scoutisme développerait
une certaine appétence pour l'engagement
et les carrières politiques
aujourd'hui encore des élus le
revendiquent comme origine de leur
action publique les éclaireurs étaient
une belle école pour ça une belle
deuxième famille pour me confronter et
et me préparer à un engagement de vie
c'est évident et d'autres racontent
comment leurs compétences politiques ont
été acquises chez les scouts
savoir te faire travailler une équipe
ensemble ça va embarquer une équipe dans
une direction commune ça je l'ai appris
aussi chez les scouts une fois qu'on a
été scout on y arrive dans toutes les
circonstances et on est destiné de façon
irrésistible à exercer des
responsabilités de commandement mais
c'est une très bonne école
le scoutisme
Herman catholique le groupe de ces
bataillons se retrouvent chez les Scouts
et Guides de France puis viennent les
Scouts d'Europe et les unitaires moins
nombreux les éclaireurs laïques et les
scouts protestants et enfin les scouts
Israélites et musulmans
à chacun son scoutisme et pourtant un
point commun reconnu par les chercheurs
en sciences sociales
[Musique]
est un espace d'expérimentation
d'apprentissage du politique il y a une
forme d'auto gestion d'auto-organisation
de scoutisme qui prépare finalement à la
discussion collective à la prise de
décision à l'engagement et à la prise de
responsabilité comment et pourquoi
s'il y a plus d'un siècle par Baden
Powell pour occuper la jeunesse pauvre
des faubourgs de Londres et devenu une
pépinière de responsable politique
[Musique]
jeune femme écologiste sa victoire à la
mairie de Poitiers il y a deux ans a été
une énorme surprise
à 30 ans Léonore m'ont conduit à évincer
le maire sortant de 72 ans mettant fin à
43 ans de gestion socialiste
est-ce que vous avez l'impression d'être
un symbole disons que c'est une
dimension dont j'ai pris conscience
après mon élection où c'était notamment
des petites filles qui m'ont dit mais
c'est vous la mer vous êtes une femme et
vous êtes jeune et il y a une espèce de
j'ai compris que pour beaucoup de jeunes
filles en particulier mon élection
voulait dire c'est possible pour moi
aussi
mais en ce début octobre la tâche
s'annonce compliquée le préfet exige
qu'elle retire une subvention à une
association qui propose des ateliers de
désobéissance civile au nom de la loi
dite séparatisme qui prévoit que tout
association remplie c'est un contrat
d'engagement républicain
pour les médias locaux c'est un peu le
sujet polémique du moment
je ne partage pas l'interprétation du
préfet sur l'application la loi mon
opinion n'a pas changé depuis le premier
le prix depuis la première réponse que
j'avais apporté
pour la conforter dans son bras de fer
avec le préfet le soir même Léonore
m'ont conduit va demander au Conseil
Municipal en vote pour le maintien de la
subvention
[Musique]
bonjour La manœuvre est risqué
mais la mer va se montrer persuasive
[Musique]
considérons-nous qu'il est interdit de
poser la question de la désobéissance
civile dans l'espace public non toutes
et tous nous saluons unanime
Martin Luther King dans nos livres
d'histoire et se faisant nous rendons
hommage à des femmes et à des hommes
dans les combats pour les droits
civiques pour l'égalité n'aurait jamais
été gagné sans une forme de
désobéissance civile je vous propose
ainsi ce soir que nous voions le
maintien à la subvention d'alternatives
y a-t-il des prises de parole
et avec vos propos que je relierai
attentivement mais qui sont chargés
d'ambiguïté qui est pour le maintien de
la subvention à la situation alternative
c'est bon
la jeune élu paraît sûre d'elle
c'est à plomb elle le tient de ses 15
années passées chez les éclaireurs et
éclaireuses unionistes de France les
scouts protestants qu'il aurait guidé
naturellement vers la politique de la
pédagogie scout c'est une pédagogie qui
encourage à prendre des responsabilités
dès le plus jeune âge et qui donne
confiance en le fait d'oser et donc oui
ça m'a donné confiance en le fait de
pouvoir être capable d'apprendre même
les choses que je connaissais pas les
missions nouvelles les projets
d'envergure
je suis pas experte à priori n'empêche
que j'ai confiance en le fait de pouvoir
progresser avec l'équipe au fil du
mandat
dans son bureau une photo révélatrice
celle du soir de sa victoire une
aventure collective car Léonore m'ont
conduit n'a pas été désigné par un parti
mais par une assemblée citoyenne très
impliquée dans sa campagne
vous voyez donc je suis au centre mais
il y a vraiment tout un collectif de
personnes le collectif c'est c'est ma
manière de fonctionner depuis que j'ai
l'âge de m'engager
chez les scouts en particulier on a
tout est structuré autour de la vie
d'équipe que ce soit la vie quotidienne
donc les tâches à faire dans la vie
quotidienne on dort en groupe on mange
en équipe
on vit des aventures en équipe et ça
c'est ça donne moi ça m'a donné vraiment
une un goût une appétence pour le
travail d'un collectif et aussi un peu
les savoir-faire qui vont avec quoi le
collectif la marque de fabrique du
scoutisme
nous sommes au premier camp de la saison
du groupe des scouts et guide de France
le plus important des mouvements ici
celui de Viroflay en région parisienne
presque 200 scout et comme toujours les
petits sont encadrés par les grands
foulard et chemise sont de rigueur
[Musique]
Marius 20 ans est étudiant en école
d'ingénieur
lui a commencé le scoutisme à l'âge de 8
ans et cette année il a voulu donner de
son temps pour le mouvement
j'ai décidé de devenir chef bah un peu
pour rendre tout ce qu'on va donner
pendant ces douzaines parce qu'il faut
savoir qu'on est bénévoles et du coup je
trouvais ça quand même j'ai adoré mes
chefs et j'aimerais bien rendre tout ce
qu'on m'a tout ce qu'on m'a donné le
maître mot l'entraide
ouvrir plus là
alors quand Marius ne sait plus comment
monter une tente
il y a forcément quelqu'un pour lui
montrer
c'est un peu galère mais on a réussi et
voilà heureusement que le chat est
expérimenté
l'expérience avant d'être chef les
enfants sont classés par tranche d'âge
chacun avec sa couleur d'uniforme et son
nom
[Musique]
les farfadets les 6-8 ans
les Janet les filles de 8 à 12 ans
alors âge les garçons s'appellent les
louveteaux
les scouts ce sont les garçons de 12 à
14 ans tandis que les fils s'appellent
les guides
puis viennent les pionniers et les
caravelles
[Applaudissements]
et je dirais des copains enfin les
compas comprenait les compagnons de 17 à
21 ans
pour symboliser le changement de tranche
d'âge il y a des rides de passage ce
qu'on appelle les montées une mini
cérémonie organisée en public un peu
comme dans le monde politique
le fait d'être porté un peu partout tout
le monde bah ça sent un peu l'esprit
communauté il y a beaucoup plus cet
aspect de voilà je rentre dans les
scouts où je monte d'un cran mais je
suis accompagné en fait et c'est ça qui
est je trouve sympa c'est que tout le
monde tout le monde assiste un peu à la
montée et ça c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
être porté cultive la confiance en
l'autre
[Applaudissements]
des souvenirs de scout Léonore m'ont
conduit en a mis la raconter j'ai mon
foulard qui est toujours le même pour le
coup c'est celui de Poitiers j'ai ce
modèle là on va dire depuis l'âge de 11
ans
je vous ai amené mon Opinel mon sifflet
qui sont les outils indispensables du
responsable scout mais pour elle le
scoutisme est aussi une école
d'apprentissage à la politique surtout
lors d'un grand classique le voyage à
l'étranger pris en charge par les jeunes
même à partir de 17 ans
nous on avait monté un projet au
Guatemala on était allé passer un mois
dans une communauté autogérée parce
qu'on voulait vraiment comprendre
comment est-ce qu'ils essayent de
fonctionner en alternative par rapport à
la société la plus conventionnelle donc
il fonctionnait presque en autonomie
alimentaire et fonctionner avec une
forme démocratique très innovante et
donc on était allé voilà vivre avec eux
pendant un mois parce que c'est une
expérience
extrêmement formatrice sur le voyage qui
était un petit peu l'aboutissement mais
avant tout parce qu'on avait passé deux
ans à préparer notre projet ensemble à
trouver nous-mêmes les fonds nécessaires
pour nous financer notre voyage trouver
nous-mêmes les partenaires apprendre à
parler espagnol pour ceux qui parlaient
pas espagnol c'est presque hors norme
par rapport à ce que la société propose
aujourd'hui où on a tendance à aller
vers davantage de protection par de
surprotection des enfants les scouts
c'est aussi une école de l'apprentissage
de l'autonomie et de l'engagement retour
au camp des Scouts et Guides de France
de Viroflay
après le montage des tentes
pas facile pour Marius d'imposer son
autorité à des louveteau pas forcément
discipliné les gars les gars on fait un
test pour ce soir s'il y a trois c'est
trop tourbulant vous serez pas après
dans l'année
pour les jeunes encadrants
[Musique]
diriger parce que le terme est un peu
fort de dire diriger quelqu'un enfin ça
fait quand même un peu plus autoritaire
mais ça prend un peu à
à conduire un groupe j'irai à conduire à
organiser à un peu guider
savoir venir un collectif et sont
pendant savoir faire bloc des qualités
essentielles en politique
ancien président du groupe lrem à
l'Assemblée nationale Gilles Legendre on
sait quelque chose moi j'ai commencé à
être à 8 ans
à ce moment-là évidemment on n'a pas
forcément le goût de la vie collective
on a plutôt le goût de la castagne de la
rivalité de la concurrence et bien
précisément le scoutisme permet de
dompter cette sentiment d'introduire une
sentiment de discipline en politique ça
n'est pas superflu et il en a gardé des
réflexes de chef scout auprès de ses
collaborateurs parlementaires ton
discours il est très bien mais je pense
qu'il faut qu'on le cheville un tout
petit peu différemment des éléments de
langage c'est le droit de proposer
versus le droit d'abroger etc etc etc on
n'a jamais parlé il m'en a jamais parlé
mais étrangement ça me surprend pas non
plus ça me surprend pas non plus qu'il
était scout en tant que louveteau Gilles
Legendre a vécu de très près une
révolution dans le monde du scoutisme la
scission chez les scouts catholiques
français
[Musique]
mon troisième frère
Olivier a fondé l'une des grandes
associations de scoutisme aujourd'hui
tout ça est intervenu trois ans après
Mai 68 et 3 ans après mes 68 le
Scoutisme Français les Scouts de France
ça s'appelait qui était le mouvement
Ultra dominant à engager une sorte de
mutation
qui était peut-être bien qui était
peut-être pas bien mais qui aboutissait
tout de même à remettre en cause pas mal
des fondamentaux du scoutisme et les
scouts unitaires de France ont souhaité
rester dans la ligne originelle et c'est
pour ça aussi que cette association a
été créée
en 1971 le scoutisme vit un véritable
schisme à la fois politique et
pédagogique
[Musique]
la société ayant évolué
il fallait que le mouvement évolue et
colle à la réalité
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
pardons plus sur cette proportion de
d'ouverture vers le monde c'est l'époque
des prêtres ouvriers c'est c'est
Lemonnier qui va qui va prendre la
guitare et chanter des chansons
populaires et toute cette dimension
voilà de d'actualisation de cette
volonté de modernisation en tout cas en
partie de des méthodes et des pratiques
dans le scoutisme catholique entraîne en
réaction un refus ou d'une partie des
membres alors des cadres des parents des
enfants également qui à ce moment-là
décident de créer leur propre
association il y a quelque chose d'assez
particulier dans le scoutisme on a
l'impression que c'est c'est un monde à
part un petit peu ringard dans les bois
or le mais complètement perméable
à l'ensemble de la société
les scouts unitaire eux sont plus
traditionnels pourtant Gilles Legendre
se souvient d'un mouvement Passi
homogène parce que certains c'est que
nous cultivions l'amour de la patrie ça
c'est absolument clair
une passion quand même un intérêt quand
même pour la chose publique c'est vrai
que tous les matins en camp on se
retrouvait tous pour monter les couleurs
mais
j'avais comme copain scout avec moi qui
portait l'uniforme scout avec moi des
copains qui le samedi
militait avec la Ligue communiste
révolutionnaire de l'époque la LCR et
aller donner le coup de poing contre
contre ce qu'on appelle les fafs du
Guide des syndicats étudiants de droite
ou d'extrême droite et et tout le monde
se retrouvait à monter des couleurs
ensemble vous voyez
à la fin de ces années de scoutisme
Gilles Legendre s'engage pour la
campagne présidentielle de Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing et son projet d'une
société plus émancipée
et aujourd'hui de quel bord politique
sont les scouts dans les camps lors des
week-ends
je pense qu'il y a pas du tout de droite
ou gauche au scoutisme parce que c'est
un mouvement qui est politique dans ces
engagements mais qui est apolitique dans
ces dans ces qui ne prend pas de partie
en fait donc je pense qu'on peut
retrouver beaucoup de opinions
différentes mais pour autant il se
retrouve sur des valeurs communes je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup d'enfants de
parents de droite alors que ça promet
beaucoup de valeurs de gauche le trou
non mais si parce que
le collectif la nature tout ça ça m'a
l'air d'être des valeurs plus de gauche
[Musique]
ce qui est lancé comme une boutade n'est
pas forcément loin de la réalité
Maxime Vanhoenacker pilote une énorme
enquête intitulée scouto il a interrogé
plus de 5200 scouts majeurs ou ancien
scout il l'aura entre autres demander
pour qui ils avaient voté aux dernières
élections présidentielles et les
résultats sont surprenants quand on
regarde les résultats de la du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle c'est
le candidat Mélenchon qui arrive
légèrement en tête devant le candidat
Macron le candidat Zemmour et puis le
candidat Jadot donc on a quelque chose
qui est très différent du reste de la
population on a beau avoir un
échantillon une population qui se dit
plutôt à droite on a quand même un vote
qui qui est plutôt
à gauche voir extrême ou au centre dans
l'enquête plus de 92% des scouts ou
anciens scouts disent s'être déplacés
pour voter c'est plus de 20 points de
plus que la moyenne nationale
d'une façon générale le scoutisme
favorise l'engagement pour les autres
[Musique]
flore 22 ans fait des études dans une
prestigieuse école de commerce à Lyon
mais c'est dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire qu'elle veut travailler dans
la droite ligne de son engagement chez
les scouts
à vivre en communauté donc forcément ça
crée un penchant pour tout ce qui est
solidaire tout ce qui est social tout ce
qui est en commun l'année dernière j'ai
été bénévole dans la prison de Lyon à
Lyon Corbas pendant toute la nuit
quasiment je fais des cours de sciences
scolaires aux femmes détenus
être au service des autres faire la BA
la bonne action c'est dans l'ADN du
scoutisme depuis Baden Powell et pour
certains ces préceptes se sont muets en
action politique
un vendredi de novembre près de Lyon
non non c'est je tiens ma permanence sur
le marché tous les mois voilà
je suis nouvelle union populaire
Gabriel Amar député du Rhône est entré
aux Éclaireurs de France le mouvement
laïque du scoutisme à l'âge de 7 ans
être immergé dans la nature lui a appris
le sens du concret
l'école bien sûr nous apprenait beaucoup
de choses mais le fait d'être toujours
tourné vers l'action et le concret c'est
ce sont les éclaireuses avec l'heure de
France très évidemment
pas de blabla il faut faire il y a un
problème il y a une souffrance il y a
une douleur il y a une difficulté il y a
une pollution
il y a un Béal qui est esquinté quelque
part allez on y va on va on va aider on
va restaurer on va se rendre utile il
faut pas faire des discours sur la
l'altruisme et l'entraide il faut faire
ça c'est les scoutisme bien sûr le
député travaille sur une proposition de
loi sur l'accès à l'eau pour tous
alors pour voir concrètement les
initiatives innovantes dans le domaine
il retrouve le Maire de Villeurbanne
bon salut
a mis en place un lieu d'accueil pour
les plus précaires
bonjour bienvenue
ici on aide les 100 abris des gens qui
vivent dans leur voiture ou des réfugiés
en leur offrant un café et l'écoute
d'une assistante sociale
ça fait une centaine de nouvelles
familles sur l'année 2021 qui est encore
pas terminée et c'est une augmentation
depuis des années précédentes mais ici
surtout on leur donne accès à l'hygiène
une buanderie avec des machines à laver
et disponible gratuitement grâce à un
lieu où il y a de la vache lava machine
pour laver
on peut venir quand même plusieurs fois
par semaine ou par un niveau genre on
prend une rendez-vous
dans un ancien vestiaire de sport des
douches sont également accessibles à
tous
[Musique]
on nous offre les serviettes les
shampoing du savon
l'accès à l'eau il y a une filiation
directement avec les scouts l'accès à
l'eau à tous quand on faisait des
collectes alimentaires ou qu'on vendait
la vignette pour la jeunesse en plein
air je crois qu'on nous a très vite
appris que il y avait des difficultés et
que dans un pays aussi riche que le
nôtre fallait vraiment faire en sorte
qu'il y ait du partage donc oui moi ça
fait que je pouvais pas me retrouver
ailleurs que du côté du peuple et de ses
colères et ses souffrances en ayant fait
13 ans aux éclaireuses électeurs de
France mais l'originalité du projet
tient aussi à sa jeunesse ce foyer a été
proposé par un juré citoyen et le
politique a suivi
sur
la démarche citoyenne à l'origine de ce
projet c'est c'est le scout Cédric van
stevendel qui doit nous en parler
ça m'a appris à transformer ce que je
savais ça m'a notamment appris aussi à
se dire que seul on fait rien en fait
globalement et que si on n'est pas
capable d'embarquer c'est ce qu'on a
fait sur ce juris citoyen ce jury
citoyen c'est pas simplement
l'intelligence citoyenne c'est aussi le
politique si il crée pas de l'appétence
et s'il crée pas de la légitimité en se
disant je ne décide pas tout seul mais
je je confronte ce que finalement le
boulot d'un député en fait on a
l'impression que c'est c'est compliqué
un boulot de député mais c'est juste que
la loi il faut qu'elle soit en phase
avec ce qu'attendent les frontières de
les Français quoi avec le réel et bien
moi voilà je crois que ça m'a appris
cela cet engagement souvent on se
retrouve en achat scout moi aussi
j'étais et en découvre ça toujours après
finalement il y a pas de hasard il y a
pas de mais par contre je pense qu'il y
a pas de trucs de réseaux
mais par contre vous avez raison de dire
on se reconnaît mais c'est en fait on se
reconnaît c'est juste il y a des il y a
des réflexes ça donne envie de faire des
choses avec les autres et surtout ça
donne on va pas vous faire les il y en a
une seule c'est laisser ce monde un peu
meilleur que vous ne l'avez trouvé en
arrivant bon voilà bah ça peut sembler
modeste pour un homme politique que de
se dire que c'est son objectif moi ça me
va déjà laisser ce monde meilleur en
partant que on arrivant c'était un bel
objectif mais ça m'amène par exemple à
passer du scoutisme à l'anti-racisme
je rappelle souvent que c'est la réforme
du Code de la nationalité et la remise
en cause du droit du sol par Pasqua qui
m'amène à passer des éclairs à
l'engagement
[Musique]
je suis rentré
dans la réforme du Code de la
nationalité
et la remise en cause du droit du sol
et nos scouts d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
parmi nos rencontres il y a Luc des gens
engagés dans le syndicat étudiant UF à
l'Université Paris Dauphine
il se dit pourquoi pas
j'habite à Versailles peut-être des
élections municipales à Versailles Parti
socialiste verset je suis pas sûr qu'il
grand monde ou Europe Écologie vers à
Versailles ça peut être marrant enfin si
il y a besoin d'aide et après le conseil
municipal pas plus quoi
et puis il y a Théo Balt étudiant à
Sciences Po Paris
vous voyez où dans 10 ans
je ne sais pas je sais pas vraiment je
me vois dans une entreprise probablement
peut-être dans la direction de
l'entreprise
en essayant d'avoir le plus d'impact
possible pour qu'elle devienne de plus
en plus responsable et pas faire de la
politique
je ne sais pas peut-être en tout cas
c'est pas dans spa dans mes projets
directs les envies des plus jeunes elles
restent assez conformes aux aspirations
de leur âge est-ce que tu sais ce que tu
veux faire dans la vie plus tard toi
pompier
vétérinaire peut-être mais ça a l'air un
peu difficile quand même mais
testeurs de sensation forte moi
j'aimerais être policière peut-être
chanteuse aussi sur les traces de notre
première ministre Nathaniel lui se voit
bien polytechniciens
tu veux faire polytechnicien plus tard
oui mais je pense que je suis déjà bien
parti
il faut savoir beaucoup de choses
et que comme ce premier de la plage je
pense que je pense que c'est peut-être
bon pour ça les chorégraphes sont
attendus
pas sûr que ces jeunes scout face un
jour de la politique mais ils seront
sans doute des adultes plus engagés dans
des associations ou des syndicats plus
solidaires pour une citoyenneté active
[Musique]